Okay.
Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig.
Und wir würden gerne mit Ihnen das Analyse gesprach führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Autole bescheiden, ich möchte ganz schnell ein paar Argumente fragen, Sie stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Ja, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Mendes. Mendes Paul.
Mendes Paul. Herr Paul, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen zustabilieren?
Nein. Mendes ist mein Nachname. M-E-N-D-E-S. Paul ist der Vorname.
Okay. Herr Mendes. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
70 Jahre alt? Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Weil wir nicht genau geboren. Das weiß ich nicht.
Am 1. April 1950. 1952. 1952. Ja, genau.
Okay. Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 170 groß und wiege 72 Kilo.
Okay, danke Ihnen. Und Herr Mendes, was führt Sie zu uns?
Was für welche Werte haben Sie momentan?
Also, es war so. Ich habe vor einer Woche hier in dieser Klinik eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung gehabt.
Okay.
Genau. Und diese Herzkatheteruntersuchung ist eine Engstelle an meinem Herz aufgemacht worden.
Und dann bin ich nach Hause gegangen und seitdem ich zu Hause bin, bin ich immer schwach.
Sehr schwach und antriebslos.
Schwach und?
Und gestern antriebslos.
Okay.
Antriebslos.
Und gestern Abend, Herr Dr. Gestern Nacht, war das so, dass ich mich umziehen wollte, ins Bett gehen wollte.
Ich wollte meine Pyjamas anziehen und dann hatte ich so einen Druck auf der Brust.
Mir ist schwindelig geworden, mir ist schwarz vor Augen geworden und konnte auf einmal nicht atmen.
Und dann habe ich mich hingelegt und dann ist das langsam besser geworden.
Und heute Morgen hatte ich immer noch Luftnot und da hat meine Frau den Notart gerufen.
Okay. Und gestern, was ist passiert? Gestern hat ihre Torte sie umgesogen und dann haben sie...
Nein, ich habe mich selber umgezogen.
Okay.
Können Sie mich da rum?
Gestern Nacht, ich wollte gestern Nacht ins Bett gehen, zum Schlafen.
Ich habe mich umgezogen und beim Umziehen ist mir schlecht geworden.
Ich hatte schwindelig, mir ist schwarz vor Augen geworden, ich hatte Druck auf der Brust und Luftnot.
Okay, Luftnot, ja.
Brustschmerzen, schwindelig, schwarz vor Augen und Luftnot hatten Sie, nächste Beschwerden.
Okay.
Und heute Morgen, können Sie wiederholen, wie heute Morgen, was passiert?
Können Sie wiederholen, was heute Morgen passiert ist.
Genau, was heute Morgen passiert ist.
Nichts, ich hatte wieder weiterhin noch Luftnot, mir ging es nicht gut, da hat meine Frau den Notart gerufen, weil ich immer noch Beschwerden hatte.
Okay, danke Ihnen.
Und, haben Sie momentan Brustschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe keine Brustschmerzen mehr.
Jetzt geht es mir wieder besser.
Genau, gestern Abend nur hatten Sie Brustschmerzen.
Nein, gestern Nacht hatte ich, ich habe die Nacht nicht gut geschlafen deswegen und jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt ist weg.
Okay.
Und jetzt messe ich hier Blutzeichen, Entschuldigung, Vitalzeichen und überprüfe ich Vitalparameter, dann Sauerstoffsetigung und so.
Deshalb, dann, ich werde vielleicht Ihnen Sauerstoff geben.
Ganz schnell mache ich diese und habe ich das gemacht und habe ich Ihnen auch jetzt Sauerstoff gegeben.
Leider sind Sie unter noch etwas...
Aber ich sage Ihnen etwas, die Sättigung von diesen Patienten war bei 98 Prozent.
98 Prozent, okay, das brauchen Sie keinen Sauerstoff.
Und jetzt, haben Sie keine Brustschmerzen, nur jetzt haben Sie leider unter Atemnot.
Auch nicht mehr, auch nicht mehr.
Ich bin jetzt nur noch schwach.
Nur schwach.
Okay, nur schwach und Antriebslosigkeit.
Okay, alles klar.
Und vor einer Woche wurde...
Schwindel, ich habe noch ein bisschen Schwindel.
Vor einer Woche war ich hier, da ist eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung gemacht worden, da habe ich einen Stand gekriegt.
Nur einen Stand, ja?
An welcher Artilie wissen Sie?
Rechte, rechte Coronatier.
Okay, jetzt schwitzen Sie.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Nachtschweiß oder Schütterfrost.
Okay, keine.
Wusten Sie?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und seit einer Woche sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden oder diese Beschwerden?
Seit einer Woche geht es mir schlecht, genau.
Schlapp.
Vorher war ich nicht schlapp, schlapp geht es.
Seit einer Woche geht es mir nicht schlapp, aber die Schmerzen hatte ich gestern Abend erst das erste Mal.
Okay, aber jetzt haben Sie keine Schmerzen und die Schlappheit oder Antriebslosigkeit und Schwache sind immer schlimmer geworden.
Nicht Schwache, sondern Schwäche.
Schwäche, Schwäche, okay.
Genau.
Sind diese Beschwerden plus die aufgetreten oder?
Ja, ich habe es ja gesagt, als ich mich umgezogen habe, ist das passiert.
Gestern?
Vorher hatte ich, genau, vorher hatte ich gar keine Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Na ja, seitdem ich entlassen worden bin, nicht gut. Ich esse nicht mehr so viel. Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Okay, haben Sie einen Gehörer ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, also nicht bestrechtlich abgenommen, auch nicht zugenommen.
Okay.
Wie ist der, oder haben Sie Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, alles in Ordnung.
Haben Sie keine Veränderung bemerkt?
Nein, da habe ich keine Veränderung bemerkt.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzstolpen?
Ich habe Vorhofflemmen.
Vorhofflemmen.
Ich habe Vorhofflemmen und das letzte Mal, als ich hier war, da war das Herz sehr schnell, hat man mir gesagt.
Und ich habe neue Medikamente bekommen.
Okay. Wann hatten Sie diese neue Medikamente bekommen?
Letztes Mal.
Letztes Mal, wann war das?
Vor einer Woche, als ich mein Herz kritisiert habe.
Vor einer Woche, okay.
Und seit wann leiden Sie unter dieser Vorhofflemmen?
Das habe ich schon Jahre, das habe ich schon lange.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie bekommen?
Wissen Sie das?
Das eine fängt mit dem an, die Gitoxin.
Das nehme ich jeden Tag ein.
Das andere ist mein Wetterblocker, das nehme ich schon Jahre ein, wie so Polon.
Da habe ich vorher 2,5 Milligramm eingenommen, 2 Mal täglich.
Jetzt habe ich 5 Milligramm 2 Mal täglich.
Jetzt nehmen Sie bis zu Polon 5 Milligramm, oder?
Ja.
Ja, jetzt 2 Mal.
2 Mal täglich, okay.
Morgens und abends.
Die Gitoxin ist einmal täglich.
Einmal täglich.
In welcher Dosierung wissen Sie?
Sie wissen nicht, okay.
Nein, die Gitoxin weiß ich nicht.
Außer diese Gitoxin und Visoplolo nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme so viele Medikamente ein.
Da nehme ich noch ein, für den Blutuch ganz viele Medikamente.
Und zwar nehme ich ein, das Amlodipin, 5 Milligramm abends.
Dann nehme ich ein Kandesaptan, 16 Milligramm, morgens.
Dann nehme ich, dann nehme ich noch ein Rosu-Wastatin, 10 Milligramm abends.
Dann nehme ich noch Medformin ein, 1000 Milligramm 2 Mal täglich.
Dann nehme ich noch ein Apixaban, 5 Milligramm 2 Mal täglich.
Moment, Entschuldigung, Medformin, 1000 Milligramm 2 Mal täglich.
Und ja, Medformin und dann noch etwas.
Apixaban, 2 Mal 5 Milligramm.
Dann nehme ich ein, das Klopidogrel, 75 Milligramm täglich.
Ja, das war alles, war nicht mich erinnern können.
Klopidogrel, wie viele Milligramm?
75.
75 Milligramm, einmal täglich.
Ja, aber Klopidogrel dürfen Sie in der Prüfung nicht tragen,
das ist immer 75 Milligramm, immer.
Okay.
Und ja, viele Medikamente nehmen sich momentan regelmäßig ein.
Das ist natürlich sehr aufpassende Situation, muss man immer vorsichtig sein.
Über diese Medikamente muss man immer...
Was heißt aufpassende Situation?
Das gibt es im Deutschen nicht.
Ja, keine, genau.
Was Wort gibt es nicht?
Was heißt aufpassende Situation?
Vorsichtig.
Wie bitte?
Süßes Missfremden.
Wie gerade die Messie gerechnet wird.
Ach so.
Okay.
Da müssen Sie gut aufpassen, reicht schon.
Okay, genau.
Da müssen Sie gut aufpassen, um diese Medikamente richtig einzunehmen.
Ja.
Und außer diese Vorurfilmen leiden Sie einer Art Bluthoff-Türk.
Und noch etwas.
Bluthoff-Türk, seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Sehr lange, Jahre schon.
Ich bin 70 Jahre lang, das habe ich schon sehr lange.
Okay.
Blutzuckerkrankheit, glaube ich.
Zuckerkrankheit, nicht Blutzuckerkrankheit.
Blutzuckerkrankheit gibt es nicht.
Zuckerkrankheit, okay.
Bitte nicht Blutzuckerkrankheit, okay.
An der Zuckerkrankheit habe ich Diabetes,
und ich nehme mit Formin ein.
Das habe ich aber auch schon Jahre.
Genau, schon Jahre.
Und noch etwas mit Erkrankungen, die ich wissen sollte.
Leiden Sie daran?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay.
Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Unverhältlichkeiten bekannt?
Nein.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay, das ist gut, Herr Mendez.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke auch kein Alkohol mehr.
Früher habe ich mal auf Feiern ein Bier getrunken,
aber oder ein Wein.
Das mache ich auch nicht mehr.
Okay, das ist schön.
Seit wann trinken Sie nicht?
Schon lange.
Ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine medizinische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Droge nehmen?
Nein.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und ich muss noch etwas über Ihre Familiengeschichte
und privates Leben an Sie stellen.
Ein paar Fragen an Sie stellen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Okay.
Sie sind in meiner Frau, geht es auch nicht so gut.
Ich muss nachher gucken.
Deswegen, ich muss ganz schnell wieder nach Hause.
Okay.
Also, Ihre Frau hat eine...
Sie gibt mir eine Erkrankung, oder?
Ja, die hat halt einen Schlaganfall gehabt,
die liegt zu Hause und ich muss nachher gucken.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Ja, das tut mir leid, aber natürlich,
wir werden alles tun, um Ihnen zu helfen.
Gut, ganz schnell oder wie schnell möglich,
nach Hause gehen können.
So schnell wie möglich.
So schnell wie möglich, nach Hause gehen können.
Alles klar. Danke, vielen Dank.
Sie wollen mit Ihrer Frau zusammen?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind diese Kinder gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Meine Kinder sind gesund.
Das ist schön.
Haben Sie geschwistert?
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder.
Sind die auch gesund?
Ja, also mein Bruder, der eine,
der ist relativ früh an seinem Herzenfall gestorben
und der andere Bruder,
der hatte einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Aber sonst geht es aber gut,
dem anderen Bruder, Gott sei Dank.
Okay, die Schlaganfall, aber jetzt geht es...
Es geht ihm gut.
Okay.
Ja, das geht gut.
Und ich glaube,
jeder Eltern
lebt nicht mehr.
Jetzt, ja.
Nein, nein, die lebe ich mehr.
Und woran sind die Eltern gestorben?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja.
Also meine Mutter ist an Krebs gestorben.
Welche Krebs?
Wissen Sie?
Ich glaube, es war Lungenkrebs.
Okay.
Ich war noch sehr klein und mein Vater,
der ist einfach alt geworden.
Ah, okay, alt geworden.
Natürlich ist es totlich.
Genau, der ist natürlich gestorben.
Genau.
Sie sind Rennner, glaube ich, jetzt?
Ja, ich bin Rennner.
Und was haben Sie vorher gemacht?
Früher gearbeitet oder...
Architekt.
Ich habe als Architekt gearbeitet.
Okay.
Ja, das ist das,
das ist das.
Okay, jetzt leidet es unter Stress oder?
Nein,
außer dass ich natürlich jetzt traurig bin
wegen meiner Frau,
weil sie halt den Schlaganfall hatte,
aber das ist ja schon länger, es geht ja auch schon ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich muss für Sie sorgen,
ich bin auch nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Sonst habe ich eigentlich keinen Stress.
Okay, das ist schön.
Aber für Ihre Frau, das tut mir leid.
Ich hoffe,
Sie kann auch guter Behandlung bekommen.
Sie wird auch bekommen.
Und können Sie gut schlafen?
Ein schlafen oder du schlafen?
Normalerweise ja,
aber gestern nicht,
weil ich beschwerben hatte.
Ja, okay.
Und wie ist die Impfstatus?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Dreimal geimpft?
Ja.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich bin auch geimpft.
Ich bin auch geimpft.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Ich gehe spazieren manchmal,
aber ich mache keinen aktiven Sport mehr.
Ja, okay.
Spaziergang ist auch gut.
Genau.
Und sind Sie in der letzten Zeit
im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Wir haben meine Frau ist ja krank.
Das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich muss diese Frage nochmal
an Sie stellen.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Sie haben gesagt, nein, ja.
Nein, ich bin nicht operiert worden.
Okay, das ist schön.
Ich muss eine Kurs zusammenfassen
für Ihre Beschwerden
an Sie machen,
für Sie machen.
Und Sie haben gesagt,
vor einer Woche,
dass Sie eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung
gehabt
oder durchgemacht.
Und Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung gemacht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht durchgemacht.
Das geht nicht.
Durchgemacht ist, wenn man eine Krankheit durchmacht.
Man kann sagen, Sie hatten
vor einer Woche eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung.
Sie hatten eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung
und wurde eine
Red Coronar Arterie
eine Engstelle
entdeckt
oder behandelt.
Und mit Stemt wurde behandelt.
Und seit einer Woche
leiden Sie unter schwere Antriebslosigkeit
und Schwindel.
Aber seit gestern Nacht beim Umzug
haben Sie bemerkt,
Nein, stopp.
Umziehen.
Umzug ist Hausumzug.
Wohnungumzug, genau.
Beim Umziehen.
Beim Umziehen haben Sie gestern Abend
Nacht Brustschmerzen
und ist Ihnen schwarz vor den Augen.
Und auch
Disney haben Sie gehabt.
Schwarz vor den Augen
geworden.
Die sind plus die aufgetreten
bei Ihnen.
Und jetzt sind
alles auch wieder weg.
Nur jetzt leiden Sie
unter Disney und
Schlappheit.
Nicht durchmacht. Luftnoten habe ich auch nicht mehr.
Ich bin einfach nur schlapp.
Ja, nur schlapp.
Das Luftnoten gestern Nacht war
da.
Genau. Bis heute Morgen.
Jetzt ist es weg.
Fährt Ihnen noch etwas ein, was
wichtig sein könnte? Nein.
Pufflemann habe ich erwähnt.
Das habe ich Ihnen ja gesagt,
dass man die Kamente umgestellt hat.
Genau.
Ja,
und
okay, und ich muss
noch etwas fragen.
Gestern Nacht, wenn Sie diese Luftnoten haben,
konnten Sie
etwas
flachlegen oder
auch nicht? Ich habe mich
danach hingelegt flach und habe geschlafen.
Ich habe mich hingelegt.
Und dann ist die Luftnot besser geworden.
Wenn Sie flachlegen, ja?
Ja, nicht flach.
Also so wie immer halt auf meinem Kissen.
Die Luftnot war nicht weg, aber die ist dann
so langsam besser geworden bis
heute Morgen.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Okay, und
möchtest du etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe von meiner Seite
alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestellt. Nein.
Nein.
Danke Ihnen.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen erklären,
wie wir vorgehen können.
Wir haben jetzt
die Analysegesprache durchgeführt
mit Ihnen.
Und werde ich
Sie köpferlich untersuchen
und von Ihnen berührt abnehmen.
Und e.g. werde ich schreiben.
Natürlich.
Und ein Herzurtraschall
und Lungen
für Ihren Brustkorb.
Ein Röntgen Torachs werde ich veranlassen.
Herzurtraschall werde ich auch
furchtführen.
Und
werde ich mit dem Oberarzt, mit
diesem Ergebnis, werde ich mit dem Oberarzt
sprechen. Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich
zu Ihnen kommen.
Und wie wir vorgehen können.
Und zunächst müssen Sie hier bleiben
für weiter Untersuchungen und Behandlungen.
Alles klar?
Okay. Danke Ihnen.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Wie lange waren Sie, Beustos?
Ich war nicht bewusstlos.
Aber Sie haben gesagt,
unmächtig. Nein, ich habe nicht gesagt,
unmächtig.
Ich habe nie gesagt, unmächtig. Ich habe gesagt,
mir ist schwindelig geworden.
Schwarz wurde in Augen.
Genau.
Schwarz wurde in Augen und mir war schwindelig.
Ich war nie bewusstlos.
Haben Sie geschwöldene Beine?
Schwollene Beine?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Früher schon
einmal
Symptome gehabt.
Haben Sie?
Nein.
Also diesen Schwindel habe ich jetzt erst
eigentlich seit einer Woche.
Aber gestern
gestern Nacht war es am schlimmsten.
Da ist mir richtig schwarz vor Augen geworden.
Ich wäre fast umgefallen.
Welche Diagnose gestartet
für die Diagnose?
Bitte.
Sie haben
die Diagnose gestartet.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Die Frage müssen Sie jetzt richtig stellen.
Okay.
Das ist ein Problem.
Ich habe nicht gesagt,
dass ich nur einfach
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Er muss weiterstellen.
Moment.
Die Frage war nicht richtig.
Sie haben gesagt,
vor einer Woche
Haben Sie die Digetoxyl bekommen?
Neun.
Und
bis zur Prüle
einmal 2,5 Milligramm
eingenommen.
Momentan 2 mal
5 Milligramm
eingenommen.
Das ist erhöht worden letztes Mal.
Ja.
Welche Diagnose
gestartet
hat sich gestartet?
Hat sich
igot?
Was war die Ursache
für die Medikamentenerhöhung zum Beispiel,
kann man sagen?
Warum sind die Medikamente
Warum haben sie die Digetoxyl bekommen?
Warum ist der Beta-Blocker erhöht worden?
Oder
Was ist die Diagnose?
Warum diese Medikamente gegeben worden sind?
Welche Diagnose ist
gestellt?
Einfach warum ist eine Diagnose gestellt?
Das hat mit der Frage nicht zu tun.
Okay.
Einfach mal benutzen.
Yes.
Sorry.
Ich habe gesagt,
dass man Herz
sehr schnell schlägt.
Das war wohl so schnell,
dass die Medikate toxin geben
mussten.
Und deswegen haben die den Beta-Blocker erhöht.
Okay.
Darf ich noch ein paar Fragen an sich stellen?
Nein, ich bin fertig.
Nein, ja.
Leiden Sie unter
Taubheitsgefühl oder Amaisenlaufen
oder Muskelschwere?
Wo?
Nein.
Muskelschwere
oder Kraftlosigkeit?
Nein, allgemeine Kraftlosigkeit.
Ich bin einfach
nicht besonders an einem Muskel.
Das habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Können wir
erst als die Schiebrennen anfangen?
Ja.
Okay, legen Sie
Klussgefühl im Herz.
Klussgefühl habe ich nichtmals. Nein.
Okay.
Hallo Frau Obererstin,
hättest du eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Ich habe neue Patienten aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Okay.
Herr Paul Mendez
ist 70 Jahre alt
und 1,70 Meter groß.
1,70, sagt man nicht.
Und 1,70 Meter groß.
1,70 Meter groß
und 72 Kilogramm
kloschwer.
Herr Paul Mendez hat sich heute bei uns
wegen
seit einer Woche bestehende
schwere Antriebslosigkeit
und Schwindel vorgestellt.
Und
die Beschwerden
seien
bis gestern Abend
gestern Nacht schlimmer geworden
und gestern Abend
den Patienten
Brustschmerzen
und Schwarz vor Augen
und Schwindel.
Seien dem Patienten geht nicht.
Gestern Abend
habe der Patient, kann man sagen,
aber Seien geht nicht.
Seien schwindel, das geht nicht.
Seien schwindel aufgefallen,
würde ich sagen deshalb.
Gestern Abend
habe der Patient Brustschmerzen
Schwarz vor Augen
und Schwindel gehabt
oder bemerkt
und Luftnot auch.
Heute Morgen
seien diese auch weggegangen
diese Beschwerden auch weggegangen
nur heute Morgen
nur habe der Patient
Antriebslosigkeit
und allgemeine
Müdigkeit
Erschöpfung oder Fatigue
und
vor einer Woche
war bei
diesem Patienten
eine Herz-Katheter-Untersuchung
oder Coronarangiografie durchgeführt
und eine
Engstelle
in der rechten Coronararterie
entdeckt
und mit
einsetzen
mit einem Stand
wurde behandelt
und seit dieser
Untersuchung
habe der Patient diese Beschwerden
außerdem
klagte der Patient
über Insomnia
und Inapetens seit einer Woche
Was ist Insomnia?
Insomnia-Einschlafstörungen
Er hat keine Einschlafstörungen
das stimmt nicht
Er hat gesagt
er konnte gestern Nacht
nicht einschlafen
weil er die Beschwerden hatte
sonst hat er keine Einschlafstörungen
seit einer Woche
in Inapetens
aber gestern
hat er ins Insomnia gehabt
Das würde ich nicht sagen
der Patient hat keine Einschlafstörungen
man kann nicht schlafen
wenn man krank ist
Einschlafstörungen sind für mich wenn man gesund ist
und nicht schlafen kann
das würde ich nicht erwähnen
besüglich der Vorerkrankung
oder
die restliche
Bekämpfung
und besüglich der Vorerkrankung
man hat der Patient
seit schon lange
bestehende
arteriale Fibrillation
dagegen nehme er
arteriale Fibrillation bitte nicht sagen
nicht in der deutschen Prüfung
Vorhofliemann
Einfach Vorhofliemann
Okay
Okay Vorhofliemann
Und
eine
seit langem bestehende
arteriale Fibrillation
und Diabetes-Bilitus
seit schon langem
und besüglich der Medikastikation
nehme der Patient
diese Degoxin
Digitoxin
sei vor einer Woche
eingestellt worden
einmal am Tag
nehme der Patient ein
bis
vor einer Woche
2,5 Milligramm
habe der Patient eingenommen
aber seit einer Woche
nehme er 5 Milligramm
zweimal am Tag ein
und am Notupin 5 Milligramm einmal am Tag
kann du an den Satran
16 Milligramm einmal am Tag
und
10 Milligramm einmal am Tag
mit Formen 1000 Milligramm
abtick samad
abtick samad 15 Milligramm
Stop
rosa was tatin
Was ist rosa was tatin
ist eine Statin
Ja genau und das ist einer der teuersten
und einer der beste, rosa was tatin
Okay
und was war das letzte Medikament
Med-Formin
Nee das letzte
Letzte abtick samad
Abtick samad
abtick samad
Abtick samad ist eine Blutgerinnung
Ja genau
Ja aber richtig sein
Abtick samad
10,12 Milligramm einmal am Tag
und klopie
Abtick samad immer zweimal am Tag
Zwei Mal am Tag, morgens und abends.
Immer zweimal.
Okay, fünf Minuten.
Welches orale Anticoagulant gibt man einmal am Tag?
Varfarin?
Varfarin, ich meine jetzt die neuen modernen Anticoagulanten.
Ich meine nicht die Vitaminkantagunnisten.
Makumal gibt man am Tag, okay.
Xarelto, Riva Ruxaban gibt man einmal am Tag.
Ab Xavan gibt man zwei Mal am Tag.
Was gibt es noch?
Xarelto, Riva Ruxaban gibt man einmal am Tag.
Und dann gibt es doch noch ein Verstens- und ein so Tradaxa.
Das gibt man oft zweimal am Tag.
Okay.
Und Klopidogrel, 75 Milligramm, zweimal am Tag.
Nehmen wir das passiert ein.
Nein!
Wie oft nimmt man Klopidogrel immer?
Wie oft gibt man Klopidogrel immer?
Immer, immer, immer für alle.
Wie oft gibt man Klopidogrel?
Einmal am Tag.
Immer!
Wie viel Milligramm?
75 Milligramm.
Immer, immer 75 Milligramm.
Immer nur einmal am Tag.
Okay.
Einmal am Tag, okay.
75 Milligramm.
Das habe ich für euch geschrieben.
Ja, okay.
Alles klar.
Das müssen Sie auswenden.
Abends.
Das ist unterschiedlich.
Wir gehen immer in der Klinik abends.
Warum?
Weil wir tagsüber Untersuchungen machen,
dann können wir abends noch absetzen.
Manchmal auf morgen fahren.
Das ist egal.
Das ist jedem selbst überlassen.
Okay.
Es gibt keine Allergie und Unverkündigkeiten.
Es sind keine Allergie und Unverkündigkeiten bekannt.
Und drogen Konsum,
Nikotinabose und Alkoholkonsum wurden vermeint.
Der Patient war verheiratet.
Und seine Frau leide an einer Apoplexie.
Hat eine Apoplexie gelitten.
Aber jetzt geht es ihr gut.
Der Patient muss auch um sich zu Hause kümmern.
Der Patient hat drei Kinder, die gesund sind.
Er hat zwei Brüder.
Eine von denen ist eine Chemieokatinfatus gestorben.
Andere haben einen einen Schmerz.
Er hat einen Schmerz.
Er hat einen eine Apoplexie gelitten.
Jetzt lebe er noch.
Und der Vater des Patienten sei gestorben.
Natürliche Tod.
Der Mutter des Patienten
sei an einer Nungenkarzin gestorben.
Und der Patient sei momentan zurzeit rennt.
Er hat vorher als Architekt gearbeitet.
Er hat keinen Stress momentan.
Und die Impfstatus sei unaufwendig.
Und vollständig.
Und der Patient macht Spaziergang.
Oder würde Spazier gehen.
Macht Spaziergänge?
Oder würde Spazier gehen?
Ja.
Die Analystischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine
Myokartinfarktus bedingte Depression.
Aber das ist falsch.
Nein.
Eigentlich habe ich auch schon Post verraten,
was es sein könnte.
Ja, manchmal nach dem.
Ich sage noch mal, sagen wir noch mal, was ist die zweite?
Was haben Sie noch für Verdachtdiagnosen?
Was könnte es noch sein?
Die Analystischen Angaben deuten am western auf eine Apoplexy hin.
Nein, warum?
Apoplexy?
Ja, wegen Fotofilmen kann auch ein Bulli...
Ja, aber hat der Ausfälle? Nein.
Neurologische Ausfälle, ehrlich, gar nicht.
Ich habe doch schon gesagt, der Patient hat...
Der Patient hat...
Schwindel. Er ist fast kollabiert.
Er ist schwarz vor Augen geworden und hatte dabei Luftnot und Druck auf der Brust.
Wenn es nicht kardial sein sollte,
wäre es, wenn überhaupt eine Luminin-Bulli könnte es sein.
Ist es dabei nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, die Sättigung ist bei 98%.
Er hat keine Sauerstoffe da.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, extra noch, damit es einfacher wird,
dass er ein Fotofilmen hat und dass er vor einer Woche wegen dem Fotofilmen,
weil das Fotofilmen zu schnell war, erneut die Getoxin
und Betablokke auf die doppelte Dosis erhöht worden ist.
Was kann jetzt die Ursache für seine Beschwerden sein?
Was macht die Getoxin und Betablokke mit dem Herzen?
Ich füber die Rose.
Was macht das mit dem Herzen?
Was macht die Getoxin?
Warum geben wir die Getoxin?
Herzschwache, Herzinsuffizienz.
Wegen Herzinsuffizienz wird digitales gar nicht mehr gegeben.
Das dürfen Sie nie sagen.
Das gibt es nicht mehr.
Bei Herzinsuffizienz gibt es kein digitales mehr.
Sie fallen wirklich durch in der Prüfung.
Ich habe schon gesagt, er hat einen sehr schnellen Herzschlag gehabt.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Fotofilmen und mein Herz hat sehr schnell geschlagen.
Die Getoxin geben wir nur, nur, nur, nur noch für Frequenzkontrolle,
damit das Herz langsamer schlägt, weil das Herz zu schnell war.
Und dann hat er auch noch den Betablokker erhöht.
Warum erhöht man den Betablokker?
Entweder wegen Herzunsuffizienz oder weil das Herz zu schnell schlägt.
Ich habe schon gesagt, ich habe Fotofilmen und mein Herz war zu schnell.
Deswegen haben wir die Getoxin neu gegeben und haben den Betablokker erhöht.
Und jetzt geht es ihm unter diesen Medikamenten.
Möglicherweise geht es ihm nicht gut.
Er ist da antrieblos, schwach und hat Schwindel.
Und jetzt ist ihm schwarz vor Augen geworden.
Druck und Luftnot. Was hat er?
Herz-Rhythmus-Sturrung.
Welche? Welche? Was passiert nämlich jetzt?
Er hat die typischen Symptome einer Bradikadie.
Er hat Schwindel, schwarz von Augen, typisch ist, dass man schwach ist, antriebslos ist,
weil man einfach, weil der Puls zu langsam ist.
Man hat natürlich, wenn man kurz so weit ist mit der Bradikadie,
dass man fast bewusstlos ist, hat man auch Druck auf den Brusten, hat man auch Luftnot.
Und das geht dann weg natürlich, wenn man sich hinlegt und zu hohe kommt.
Er hat sich angestrengt.
Er hat sowieso einen niedrigen Puls, nachts fällt der Puls nochmal etwas ab
und dann ist es noch schlechter geworden.
Er hatte Bradikadie gehabt.
Er hat einfach eine Bradikadie.
Genau, ja.
Aber das war, war das so schwer?
Ja, war es schwer?
Ja, Bradikadie hätte ich natürlich denken müssen, aber...
Ja, vielleicht, als ich gesagt habe, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Es geht ja um das Anamnesegespräch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so wichtig ist, die Diagnose richtig zu stellen.
Es geht ja darum, dass man Differenzialdiagnose noch stellt.
Was es aber noch sein könnte, ist, was man bei den Patienten sein könnte, ist...
Ja, genau, warum?
Wir haben auch Schwindel, Luftnot und Druck auf der Brust.
Das könnte natürlich auch sein, oder zum Beispiel älterer Patient.
Die Sektion, Orten, die Sektion, kann auch sein.
Ja, aber das kann man alles schnell ausschließen,
wenn man mit D-Dimäherer macht.
Wenn die D-Dimäherer negativ ist, dann hat der keine Orten in die Sektion,
dann hat der auch keine Luminambulee.
Genau, ja.
Und wenn wir die ganz schnell Vitalparameter auch überprüfen, dann geht er in die Bradikadie.
Dann werden Sie sehen, dass er nur noch ein Puls von 38 hat.
Er hat eine Sinus-Bradikadie.
Der ist jetzt wieder im Sinus-Rhythmus.
Er hat keinen Kurs, wie man mehr.
Aber jetzt hat er nur noch ein Puls von 38.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Können Sie wieder hauen, die Frage?
Er hat jetzt ein Kurs von 38.
Ja, 38.
Sinus-Bradikadie, er ist im Sinus-Rhythmus.
Und hat keinen Vorfluss, man ist im Sinus-Rhythmus,
aber der Puls ist zu langsam.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit den Patienten?
Therapeutisch.
Atropin?
Atropin, warum?
Nicht.
Man geben sehr atropin, im Notfall.
Wann?
Wenn der Patient kardial einbricht.
Das heißt, wenn der zu Blutdruck schlecht wird,
wenn er so bradikatisch ist,
das erschwindelt und kurz wird.
Ne, hat er ja nicht 38.
Da müssen Sie keine,
Sie müssen ja an den Monitor nehmen, überwachen.
Ja, jeder Patient, der so bradikatisch muss überwacht werden.
Das heißt, wir nehmen den an die CPU oder wo auch hin.
An den Monitor, überwachen den.
Okay, das haben wir jetzt gemacht, wie überwachen den,
weil er jetzt radikatisch ist.
Und was machen die noch?
Ich meine, das ist ja schon richtig.
Der Patient liegt wirklich bei mir.
Dieser Patient ist heute Nacht zu uns auf die Station gekommen.
Anderes Alter, der ist 90 Jahre alt,
und der heißt auch anders, aber alles andere stimmt.
Das erste Wochen, wo man natürlich auch denkt ist,
könnte er auch einen Herzenfakt wieder haben.
Trotzdem, deswegen,
das heißt, Sie machen die Herzenfüme natürlich alle mit,
Troponien machen Sie mit.
Und eine Herzultraschall, ne?
Ja.
Das Herzultraschall war unauffällig, das war gut.
Der pumpt gut und hat keine Wandbewerbungsstörungen.
So, und das Troponien ist jetzt bei 120.
Aber vor einer Woche war das Troponien noch bei 400.
Das heißt, es ist abgefallen, das ist nicht schlimm.
Ja.
Und Sie machen dann noch ein zweites Troponien oder nicht?
Kann ich noch mal auch kontrollieren.
Müssen Sie?
Müssen, okay.
Den Herzenfakt können Sie nur ausschließen,
wenn Sie ein zweites Troponien machen.
Und wie soll das zweite Troponien sein,
wenn das erste bei 120 ist,
damit wir den Herzenfakt ausschließen können?
Ja, wie muss es sein?
Wenn niedrige Troponien ist, dann können wir ausschließen.
Ja, wenn das erste Troponien 120 ist,
wie muss das zweite Troponien sein,
damit Sie sagen können, er hat keinen Herzenfakt?
Ah, okay.
Unter 60?
Sie haben geraten.
Ja.
Nein, nicht raten.
Es muss ungefähr 110, 120 in dem Bereich sein.
Wie viel Prozent darf es abfallen
und wie viel Prozent darf es ansteigen,
damit wir sagen können,
oder muss es abfallen und ansteigen,
damit wir sagen können, das ein Herzenfakt.
50%?
Das ist ein Herzenfakt.
50% ist die Grenze.
Okay, das heißt, wenn Sie ein Troponien von 18 haben,
18, 18 haben, wenn,
wie muss das zweite Troponien sein,
damit Sie sagen können, er hat einen Herzenfakt?
50% von 18 sind 9, 18 plus 9 sind 27.
Ja.
Nein, doch 27.
Wenn das zweite Troponien bei 27 ist,
dann hat er einen Troponienanstehung.
Und wenn es unter 27 ist, ist alles gut.
Und wenn dieser Patient jetzt ein Troponien von 120 hat,
dann ist das relevant, wenn er ein Troponien von 180 hat.
Das zweite.
120, die Hälfte sind 60, 120 plus 60 sind 180.
Hat er aber nicht.
Er hatte das zweite Troponien bei 110.
Und es darf auch nicht zu viel abfallen.
Das heißt, wenn der seit seinen Troponien von 60 hat,
hat er auch einen Herzenfakt.
Weil das 50%, mehr als 50%,
darf es nicht differenzieren.
Also differieren meine ich.
Verstanden?
Ja.
Okay, hatte er nicht.
Im Fakt haben wir ausgeschlossen, das muss man machen,
Echo haben wir gemacht, haben wir gesagt,
im Fakt haben wir ausgeschlossen, immer zwei Troponien,
120, 117 war alles gut.
Wir haben ihn trotzdem an der Überwachung gelassen,
weil wir alle Patienten 24 Stunden überwachen,
die eine Praktika, die haben und symptomatisch sind.
Er war ja symptomatisch, ne?
Ja.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie denn noch bei der Therapie?
Ganz wichtig.
Ich habe gesagt, er hat Digitoksin.
Was machen Sie?
Was bestimmen Sie im Labor?
Digitoksin-Spiegel.
Und der war bei ihm erhöht.
Der war über der Norm.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Im Labor, oder?
Ja.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Im Labor.
Oder als Therapie, was mache ich?
Ja.
Als Therapie, wenn die Koksin erhöht wird,
soll ich die Medikamente-Bettoblöcke reduzieren.
Ich rede vom Digitoksin.
Wenn der Digitoksin erhöht ist,
was mache ich jetzt mit dem Digitoksin?
Reduzieren.
Nein, absetzen, Pause.
Pause und am besten ganz absetzen.
Ja, bei den Patienten.
Was man später machen kann, ist,
wenn der Spiegel wieder normal ist,
muss man gucken, dass man fünf Tage
und Samtags-Somtagspause oder so zum Beispiel.
So machen wir das manchmal.
Aber erst mal absetzen.
Das muss sich erstmal normalisieren.
Was machen wir mit dem Bettoblöcker wieder?
Reduzieren.
Richtig, wieder auf 2,5, 2-mal.
So haben wir das gemacht.
Die Frequenz, gucken wir mal jetzt.
Wenn die Frequenz normal ansteigt,
braucht er keinen Schrittmacher.
Ist egal, ist egal.
Ich wollte nur wissen,
dass die Digitoksin-Spiegel machen müssen.
Und wenn das erhöht ist, absetzen.
Es gibt eine Medikamente,
dass wir Patienten geben können,
um die Bredikate zu normalisieren.
Keine Medikate.
Ja, atropieren schon.
Aber nur für den Notfall.
Nur für den Notfall atropieren.
Aber sonst zum Herzfrequenz ansteigt, gibt es nichts.
Das Einzige, was wir machen können,
ist, Digitoksin absetzen,
Bettoblöcker reduzieren.
Oft machen wir auch mal Bettoblöckerpause
und gucken, was passiert.
Alles andere ist zu detailliert für sie.
Es ist keine Kardälonprüfung.
Ich wollte nur wissen, dass der bei die Kart ist,
dass er überwacht werden muss
und dass sie trotzdem einen Pfad ausschließen müssen.
Natürlich sind zwei Troponien machen müssen.
Wenn der 24 Stunden an der Überwachung ist am Monitor,
dann brauchen sie auch keinen Langzeitdiktadier mehr.
Bei der war ja 24 Stunden am Monitor.
Das sehen wir am nächsten Tag.
Wir konnten ja alles durchgucken.
Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
War das zu schwer?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Für mich ist es schwer.
Ja, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
einfachen Sachen kann jeder.
Aber das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Danke Ihnen.
Das war für mich natürlich sehr gut.
Ich meine, Sie sprechen natürlich sehr gut Deutsch.
Sehr schnell, sehr gut.
Ich musste deswegen immer stopp sagen,
damit es immer langsamer werden,
damit ich korrigieren kann.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte.
Danke Ihnen.
Vielleicht, wenn ich...
Ich habe Ihnen auch gut geholfen.
Danke Ihnen.
Gut erkenntnisse haben Sie uns gegeben.
Das ist auch für uns sehr wichtig.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Ich glaube, in der Prüfung ist es wirklich nicht wichtig,
die richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
sondern die franzialen Diagnosen zu stellen.
Und dass der Prüfer weiß, der macht sich Gedanken.
Es könnte das sein, es könnte dies sein.
Ich gucke mir das an, deswegen kann es das nicht sein.
Aber es war gut.
Ich sprich gut Deutsch, ne?
Danke Ihnen.